the reason some people don't enjoy their
lives is because their container their
heart is contaminated with so many
things are you flying solo or do you
have a community of faith people flying
with you watching over you encouraging
you inspiring you if you're always
speeding negative thoughts thinking I'll
never get well I'll never meet the right
person you're feeding doubt feeding
mediocrity feeding fear
hello elimination my name is Evan
Carmichael my 1 were to believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today I'm going
to learn from pastor and New York Times
bestselling author Joel Osteen it might
be on the top 10 you'll success vol 2
rule number 5 is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the bun and as always as you're
watching if you something that's really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below
so poke through other people can be
inspired I'm going to prior as well and
also when you write it down just much
more likely to stick for yourselves as
well enjoy
[Music]
it's easy to go through life holding on
to things that are weighing us down
guilt resentment doubt worry the problem
is when we allow these things in there
taking up space for the good things that
should be there imagine your life is
like a container you are created to be
filled with joy peace confidence
creativity but if you allow worry in it
pushes out the peace there's not space
for both you can't go above a hundred
percent you have a limited amount of
room if you allow guilt to take up space
that space that you don't have for the
confidence you need and the reason some
people don't enjoy their lives is
because their container their heart is
contaminated with so many things they
have ten percent worried stressed out
over their job twelve percent bitterness
mad at their neighbor 20 percent guilt
beating themselves up for past mistakes
nine percent jealousy their co-worker is
more beautiful they don't realize
seventy percent of their container is
negative they wonder why they don't have
joy creativity passion they only have
room for 30 percent of what they should
have
the scripture says give no place to the
enemy it's not just talking about forces
of darkness that means give no place to
guilt give no place to worry give no
place to bitterness it can't come in and
automatically take over you control
what's in your container you control
what you think about what you choose to
allow in when we all have negative
emotions negative feelings you have to
make the choice I'm not going to give
this jealousy this bitterness this anger
valuable space and let it poison my life
I'm going to protect what I allow in me
and every morning when we wake up we
need to empty out anything negative from
the day before somebody offended you at
work
they didn't tweet you're right it's easy
to let that offense stay feels good to
carry around a grudge so you have to be
disciplined say no I am NOT giving this
offense any room I am NOT going to let
it sour my day they hurt you once don't
let them continue to hurt you by holding
on to the offense being offended is not
harming them it's harming you it's
taking up space you need for the good
things that move you towards your
destiny take inventory of what you're
giving space - life is too short to go
through it with negative things holding
us down there's a large company that has
a slogan that says that was easy
a few years ago a friend of mine sent me
their big red button when you push it it
says now I keep this by my bathroom sink
there on the counter
every so often I reach over and push
this button I like to get that phrase
down in my spirit because it's easy to
go through life looking at our problems
focus on our obstacles thinking oh man
this is going to be so hard I dread
dealing with this it's never going to
work out that's mindset is not only
stealing our joy but it's keeping us
from seeing God's favor when my dad went
to be with the Lord and I first started
ministering it took everything I had to
write a message for that weekend all my
focus my creativity my energy I was
pressured stressed when I finally
finished I felt like that's the last one
that I could ever do and if I wasn't
careful I was tempted to dread it and
think this is too hard I'm not going to
know what to say I can't do this anymore
I had to turn it around father thank you
that your yoke is easy thank you that
I'm well able thank you that you've
equipped me and empowered me I got my
mind going in the right direction
I went through seasons of struggle
strain difficulty but I didn't let it
become permanent in my thinking one day
I came into this anointing of ease what
once was a struggle is
not a struggle anymore every week when I
finish a message I hit this button just
to remind me that it was even quit
telling yourself this is so hard
I'll never accomplish my dreams I'll
never get out of debt this is a new day
it's easy to do life on our own and
think we don't need any help but you
won't reach your highest potential by
yourself God has ordained people to come
into your life to strengthen you to
encourage you to push you toward your
purpose you've seen birds that fly in
formation when geese make that V it
takes 40% less energy for them to fly
they could do it by themselves but they
understand this principle they won't go
as far if they fly solo are you flying
solo or do you have a community of faith
people flying with you watching over you
encouraging you inspiring you after the
football game the other night the star
running back was being interviewed he
had a great game set a record for the
amount of yards he had rushed the
reporter asked him how he did it the
first thing he said was it was because
of my offensive line those guys that
blocked for me they're the best and my
coaches that poured into me and made me
better my trainers have helped me to get
stronger he recognized that we need each
other you can be good by yourself but
you can't be great by yourself you won't
become all you were created to be
without the right people around you you
can go 60% but when you get in formation
when you have a family of faith blocking
for you praying for you encouraging you
you'll go 40% further too often we base
our value on how someone is treating us
how successful we are how perfect of a
life we've lived the problem is all of
those things can change if you're
getting your value out of how people
treat you then if they hurt you they
disappoint you you're going to field
eval
you if you're basing your value off of
your achievements how much you make what
you drive the title behind your name
then if something happens and you don't
have that position your business goes
down then your value will go down and
some people don't feel good about
themselves because they've made mistakes
in life they're not where they thought
they would be now they're living
insecure feeling inferior they're basing
their value on their performance how
someone treats you doesn't change your
value what they say or do doesn't lessen
who you are mistakes you've made doesn't
decrease your value that's what you did
that's not who you are you can buy a
bigger house drive a better car but that
doesn't make you any more valuable that
increases your net worth not your
self-worth
you are already valuable when you had
the small apartment and no title behind
your name that position may give you
more influence but not more value you
can be a stay-at-home mom raising your
children you may not have the influence
of the CEO but you have the same value
value is not based on what you do what
you make who you know that's superficial
those things can change the enemy works
overtime trying to devalue us he'd love
for you to go through life letting what
people say make you feel inferior
comparing your life to somebody else's
thinking you'll feel good about yourself
when you catch up to them when you live
in that neighborhood or when you perform
perfectly when you break the addiction
then you'll feel valuable but nothing
you do will make you any more valuable
nothing you achieve nothing you overcome
you are valuable right now God calls you
a masterpiece
you are one-of-a-kind you didn't come
off an assembly line
you aren't mass-produced God made you
unique
there will never be another you put your
shoulders back start carrying yourself
with confidence you have been fearfully
and wonderfully made we may not realize
it but we're always feeding ourselves
what we watch listen to the people we're
around the thoughts we're dwelling on
that's feeding our inner man if you go
to lunch with people that talk bad about
the boss make fun of a co-worker put
down a friend they're feeding you gossip
feeding you jealousy feeding you
disrespect here's the key
whatever you feed is going to grow you
may not like what they're feeding you
you're a nice person but if you continue
to hang around them before long you'll
be gossiping you'll be critical you'll
be disrespectful why because you kept
feeding the wrong things if you're
always feeding negative thoughts
thinking I'll never get well I'll never
meet the right person you're feeding
doubt feeding mediocrity feeding fear a
man told me how he spent years of his
life on drugs and alcohol it had ruined
his marriage he wasn't there for his
children now he was so down on himself
so discouraged what was he doing feeding
the guilt feeding the regret feeding the
blame if you feed guilt it's going to
get bigger if you feed fear it's going
to become larger what if you spent that
same energy feeding your faith feeding
your hopes feeding your dreams what are
you allowing in your spirit the people
you're spending time with the thoughts
you're dwelling on all day is that
inspiring you building your faith
pushing you towards your dreams or is it
junk food feeding you guilt mediocrity
negativity causing you to compromise a
print of mine was diagnosed with a
serious illness the doctor put him on a
very strict diet he couldn't leave any
sugar any flour any meat it was only raw
vegetables nuts grains very limited and
I asked him if he was going to do it he
said what do you mean
going to do it I don't have a choice my
life depends on it
today I'm putting you on a new diet not
physically but for your inner man no
more junk food no more dwelling on
thoughts of worry fear I don't have what
it takes no more hanging around people
that are feeding you negativity causing
you to compromise
no more guilt condemnation I'm all
washed up your prescription is for faith
food feed your hopes feed your dreams
feed your confidence feed your destiny
see did I have faith be easy to believe
for your dreams but faith without
patience can get you into trouble what
you're believing for may be taking
longer than you thought
you're not making progress not seeing a
dream come to pass but God knows what
he's doing
don't try to force things to happen you
don't have to promote yourself
manipulate people convince them to like
you yes we should be determined but you
don't have to beat down a door at the
right time things will fall into place
at the right time the right people will
show up
now do your part and wait for the
promise to unfold you're not falling
behind you're not being left out you're
right on schedule when we've been
believing for our dreams to come to pass
for a long time or problems to turn
around and we don't see anything
happening we're not making progress
we're not getting good breaks it's easy
to lose our passion and not expect two
things to change it's been that way so
long we start accepting it I'll never
get well I'll never break this addiction
I'll never accomplish my goals I tried I
prayed I believe but it didn't work out
that may have been true in the past but
I believe you are entering into a new
season you're coming in to a hard time
hard time is when things suddenly change
in your favor
hard time is when blessings chase you
down you don't have to go after them
they come after you hard time is when
you're healing shows up you meet the
right person you break the addiction God
makes things happen that you couldn't
make happen now if you're going to see
this high time there's something you
have to do wake up out of your sleep
that means get your passion back start
believing again start expecting things
to change start talking like it's going
to happen you can't sleep through your
hard time and see God's favor you can't
be complacent and step into the fullness
of what God has in store the amplified
version says it's a critical time it
stresses the importance of the season
it's saying don't take it lightly don't
dismiss and say oh this isn't for me
today if you don't stir your faith up
you can miss the new things God wants to
do what you're believing for is not way
off in the distance is closed if at hand
it could happen today live with this
expectancy there has to be an
anticipation in your spirit that today
could be my day too many people go
around feeling wrong on the inside they
don't really like who they are they
focus on their faults weaknesses they're
constantly critical toward themselves
that recording of everything they've
done wrong is always playing in their
mind you're impatient you blue your diet
yesterday you lost your temper you're
still struggling with that addiction you
should be ashamed of yourself they
wonder why they're not happy it's
because they have this war going on on
the inside if you're not supposed to go
through life feeling wrong about
yourself quit focusing on your faults
quit over analyzing your weaknesses quit
beating yourself up because you're not
where you thought you would be you may
have some weaknesses we all do there may
be some areas where you know you need to
improve
move but being down on yourself is not
going to help you do better
having that nagging feeling telling you
you don't measure up God's not pleased
with you you'll never get it right it's
not going to help you move forward you
have to accept yourself right where you
are false and all one of the biggest
challenges we all face is getting along
with people because everyone is
different we have different
personalities different temperaments we
come from different backgrounds when
somebody doesn't agree with us they do
something we don't like it's easy to get
in conflict within argue try to
straighten them out prove our point
before long read odds mad at each other
living offended their stress tension in
the home what's happened we've allowed
strife in strife is a spirit just like
teeth is a spirit you've walked into a
place before you don't know anybody
you've never been there but you can feel
the tension in the room in the
atmosphere there's stress discord nobody
said anything but you know something is
not right that's the spirit of strife if
we would see it as the destructive force
that it is we would be more careful
about allowing it in our lives after all
it's easy to argue especially with those
closest to you let's be real your spouse
can get on your nerves you love the man
you can't live without him sometimes you
feel like choking him a reporter asked
Billy Graham if he'd ever thought about
divorce
he said divorce no but murder yes
when we let our guard down and say
things that are hurtful disrespectful
demeaning that's not only damaging the
relationship that's opening the door to
strife that's inviting that destructive
spirit into our life that's why the
scripture says give no place to the
enemy strife can't just come in when it
wants bring division disharmony tear
relationships apart we have to open the
door and I'm not saying that we should
never have an argument never say a wrong
word that's not reality but when it
comes a part of who we are it becomes
common we're constantly arguing fighting
being disrespectful that means we've
gone way too far it's easy to let the
pressures of life weigh us down we have
traffic to deal with bills to pay people
that are rude if we're not careful we'll
look up and we don't smile as much we're
not as friendly we never laugh never
have fun anymore we have too much
pressure too much responsibility to
enjoy life but God didn't create you to
live with the heaviness you're not
supposed to go around solemn serious all
the time burdened down by problems
taking time to laugh to have fun that we
energizes you it helps keep you in
balance if it's all work all stress all
dealing with problems that's going to
weigh you down you can get so busy
raising your children changing diapers
getting them to school making sure their
homework is done that you don't enjoy
your children it's all work no time for
play sometimes we think we have to be
serious to show that we're responsible
but you can be responsible and
good-natured at the same time have you
let the pressures of life weigh you down
are you always solemn always serious if
you don't make this adjustment not only
will you not enjoy your life to the fall
but you won't have
relationships nobody wants to be around
a grumpy sour person that pushes people
away
thank you guys so much for watching I
mean this meeting because tableau by
Ashley so there's a favorite transfer
that zooming to profound fact check out
the link in the description you can go
and tackle both alpha let us know which
clip resonates and most of you what lets
me to take this video and immediately
apply human life or to business somehow
leave it on the comments below I'm
really curious that's what you have to
say I also want to give a quick shout
out to surge wisdom surgery wisdom thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
poster one word and making multiple
videos on YouTube channels covering all
the different chapters in my book thank
you so much ranks and support and it's
so classes enjoyment thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you hope
you teach to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
[Music]
but living guilty doesn't do anything
productive it doesn't help you to do
better it causes you to struggle more
guilt drains you emotionally physically
it will wear you out when we're guilty
we don't pursue dreams we don't believe
to overcome challenges we get stuck this
is why the enemy works overtime in this
area
he knows guilt will keep you from your
destiny there's nothing he would love
any more than for you to go through life
against yourself focus on your failures
feeling unworthy you can't drag
yesterday's failures into the day and
live in victory let it go
God's mercies are fresh every morning
don't spend another minute down on
yourself living in regrets when those
voices reminds you of everything you're
not one of the best things you can say
is I am righteous I am holy
I am blameless I am honorable everything
in your mind will say no you're not you
have an addiction you keep giving in to
the temptation you made those mistakes
but when you declare I am righteous you
are announcing to every force that's
trying to stop you you're announcing to
the accuser to the guilt to the
heaviness you don't control my life you
don't determine my destiny you can't
stop my purpose the creator of the
universe made me righteous